in the third episode of the final season
of Game of Thrones
we finally paid witness to the epic
Battle of Winterfell it was the ultimate
clash of Ice and Fire and many major
characters met their untimely doom here
are 12 details you might have missed and
warning spoilers are coming when Arya
hands Sansa a weapon for the crips Sansa
says she doesn't know how to use it -
which are you responds stick it with the
pointy end her tongue-in-cheek advice
recalls Jon's words when he gave her
needle in the second ever episode of the
show first lesson stickin with the
pointy end I know which end to use it's
a fan favorite piece of dialogue that
inspired the name of season 1 episode 8
the pointy end to light up the blades of
the Dothraki Melisandre recites a phrase
I excuse ownio which in Valyrian Medes
Lords light it's the same spell that
Barrett uses to ignite his own sword
however unlike Melisandre Barrett can
merely think of the words and a flame
will appear in the midst of all the
flames the hound is momentarily
immobilized with fear he is after all
pyro phobic a consequence of the burn
trauma inflicted on him by his brother
gregor clegane
i heard what your brother did to you
crush your face to the fire like you're
a nice juicy mutton chop
when Lyanna Mormont dies she takes one
of the White Walkers biggest assets with
her stabbing the white giant in the eye
he collapses at the same place in
Winterfell where one one fell from an
arrow in the eye after the Battle of the
bastards
when beric Dondarrion sacrifices himself
to save Arya he holds his body in the
doorway in the figure of a cross
it's a christ-like pose and a fitting
death for a figure who's been
resurrected time and time again so why
you you think I don't ask myself that
every hour of every day why am I here
what am I supposed to do in his last
moments the devout barek finally found
his true purpose the reason the Lord of
Light allowed him to be brought back
from death so many times it was
ultimately to save Arya so that she
could go on to kill the night king but
before that Arya finds herself reuniting
with Melisandre back in season 3 the red
woman predicted that they meet again and
the Arya would shut many eyes forever
brown eyes
blue eyes very nice
eyes you'll shut forever blue eyes of
course refers to those of the night king
a turning point comes in the battle when
Melisandre reminds arya of the motto
recited by her sword instructor Syrio
Forel that is only one God and His name
is death and there is only one thing we
say to death not today the culmination
of the battle in the godswood was
foreshadowed in one of Theon Greyjoy's
first ever scenes in the series the
moment comes right after Catelyn Stark
says she thinks the Lannisters purposely
pushed bran out of the window if it's
war they want it comes to that you know
I'll stand behind you is there going to
be a battle in the godswood Arya
ultimately kills the night king with the
cat's paw the dagger that bran had given
her at the same spot under the godswood
back in season 7 it's likely he knew
that she needed to slay the night king I
don't want it be sure it's fair in steel
the blade has lived a long life as it
was used by the Lannisters hit man in an
attempt to kill bran in season one
Arya plunges the dagger right into the
night Kings chest exactly where the
children of the forest stopped him with
dragonglass which we saw in brans vision
back in season 4
[Applause]
he was created by dragonglass and
uncreated by Valyrian steel because it
was so dark you may have not been able
to make out all the deaths that happened
in this episode so here's a quick
rundown of some of the major characters
who fell head tallit kono
beric Dondarrion Lyanna Mormont Jorah
Mormont Theon Greyjoy and Melisandre and
don't worry ghosts made it out alive he
appears in the teaser for episode 4 did
we miss anything let us know in the
comments
[Music]